ja und was es braucht das weiß womöglich
am ehesten der man der uns nun
zugeschaltet ist Achmad Mansur er ist
Psychologe und Buchautor zu Themen der
Integration hat eine Initiative
gegründet die das Ziel hat das
Zusammenleben gerade in Brennpunkten zu
verbessern guten Tag kann man so haben
die Ereignisse der Silvesternacht sie
überrascht
guten Tag leider nicht das ist auch
meine Kritikpunkt da der Debatte dass
wir das immer punktuell betrachten
solche Zustände gab es in Berlin gab es
in Stuttgart in Frankfurt in Brüssel in
Paris und da sollten wir vielleicht
allgemeiner äh diese Phänomene anschauen
und vor allem lösungsorientiert auch
debattieren sie sprechen es an dass viel
nicht vom Himmel es gab andere
Ereignisse in der Vergangenheit hat die
Politik da bislang zu wenig getan
absolut also die Politik vermeidet das
Thema es ist nicht cool es ist nicht gut
über das Thema zu sprechen weil man ja
auf Twitter vielleicht auch paar
kritische Kommentare bekommt aber das
ist nicht die verantwortungsvoller
Politik die ich mir für dieses Land
wünsche nun gibt es aber Stimmen die
eine Debatte fordern was das für Täter
sind welche Rolle möglicherweise auch
misslungene Integration spielt andere
sagen das ist die falsche Frage wie
sehen Sie das
das ist genau das was eigentlich die
Debatte in Deutschland auch in den
letzten Jahren gepredigt oder geprägt
hat und das ist auch das Problem dass
wir nicht in der Lage sind
weiterzukommen mit der Ursachenforschung
das ist viel wichtig natürlich spielt
auch so zur ökonomische Gründen eine
Rolle aber es spielen auch Sozialisation
eine Rolle spielt auch die Ablehnung des
Rechtsstaates eine Rolle und das ist
natürlich was mit Integration oder mit
dies Integration zu tun aber das
anzusprechen ist der erste Schritt um
überhaupt Richtung Lösung zu gehen aber
da hakt es in unsere Gesellschaft in der
letzten Jahren und was wäre der zweite
Schritt
dass wir diese Menschen erreichen also
auch die Lösungen sind natürlich nicht
einseitig auch diejenigen die
Abschiebung rufen haben es nicht
verstanden auch diejenigen die nur
sozusagen diese Menschen alles Opfer
unsere Gesellschaft sehen haben es nicht
verstanden die Lösungen sind vielsichtig
das hat mit
härtere Strafen zu tun das hat aber auch
mit präventions- und Integrationsarbeit
zu tun Begegnung wir müssen diese
Menschen erreichen bevor sie dann diesen
Weg schlagen bevor Sie bereit sind auch
dann Polizisten oder Rettungskräfte
anzugreifen und das fängt in den Schulen
in den dekorationskurse in den Arbeit
die man tagtäglich macht um diese
Menschen für diese Gesellschaft zu
gewinnen bei denen vor allem jungen
Männer die diesen Weg aber eingeschlagen
haben zeigt sich dass viele den
Rechtsstaat ignorieren verhöhnen gab in
manchen Vierteln nicht nur Silvester
sondern das ganze Jahr über wie
gewachsen wie gefährlich sind diese
Strukturen aus ihrer Sicht
naja wenn man die Gangster Rap-Szene
anschaut wenn man Jugendkultur insgesamt
anschaut vor allem was Männlichkeit
Bilder angeht dann sollte man nicht
überrascht sein das sind die Produkte
genau diese Denkweisen und
sozialisationen und da mussten wie viel
tun um diese Menschen zu erreichen vor
allem Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
die das Gefühl haben Polizei ist ihr
fein Polizei ist schwach Rechtsstaat
kann ihn nicht das ist dann das was dazu
führt dass diese Menschen bereit sind
sogar Gewalt anzuwenden um genau diese
Feindbilder zu attackieren und da ist
ganz großer Nachholbedarf was die
Debatte angeht was die Unterstützung und
die Solidarität gegenüber polizei und
Rettungskräfte angeht was sie fordern
ist dann ja nicht weniger als ein
Bewusstseinswandel
Strafverschärfung gab es schon in der
Vergangenheit die haben offenbar wenig
gebracht was braucht stattdessen
also ich sehe das in der Realität
eigentlich gar nicht ich bin sehr oft
unterwegs auch im Gefängnissen und ich
habe das Gefühl vor allem in Berlin
haben die Jugendliche das Gefühl sie
haben Freischein sie können alles machen
ich treffe immer wieder auf Jugendlicher
in anderen Gefängnissen anderen
Bundesländern die sagen mein Fehler war
dass ich nicht in Berlin sozusagen
inhaftiert wurde da muss Berlin
natürlich auch die
Rechtsstaat die schon existiert also
brauchen keine neue Gesetze einfach
durchsetzen und Botschaften vermitteln
das Angriffe auf Polizisten keine Sache
die man einfach tolerieren darf in
diesem Land Einschätzung von Ahmad man
so vielen Dank für das Gespräch